ثمان وثلاثون جائزه نصيب قناه العربيه من
جوائز تالي العالميه في نسختها 44
الجائزه التي تنظم السنويا في الولايات
المتحده تقدم لارفع الانتاجات التلفزيونيه
وتقدم في فئات ثلاثه
ذهبيه مفضيه وبرونسي
الجائزه تعد واحده من اهم الجوائز
المتخصصه في مجال تقييم محتوى الفيديو
والانتاج المرئي بمشاركه بئتي خبير من
مؤسسه اعلاميه وقنوات وشركات انتاج دوليه
ضمن الفئات التي ربحت جائزه التالي خمس
جوائز ذهبيه كانت من نصيبي ثلاثه برامج
وتغطيه على الصعيد البرامج برنامج على خطى
العرب ومهمه خاصه وعسكري تاريا اما على
الصعيد التغطيه فكانت من نصيب تغطيه
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه وكذلك تقرير
نفذ بتقنيه الواقع الافتراضي من هو بيض
جوائز تالي التي حازتها قناه العربيه كانت
ضمنها عشرون جائزه فضيه وثلاثه عشره جائزه
من البرونزيه
ذهبت لعدد من برامج العربيه وتغطياتها
الخاصه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والوثائقيه
وبرامجها على مواقع التواصل والتصميم
الابداعي واستخدام الواقع المعزز
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات